pierre bédier au chevet des commerçants
de cheuvreux ce mardi 2 mars le
président du département s'est rendu
dans plusieurs boutiques
il a vérifié à cette occasion la mise en
place d'un dispositif des aides
d'urgence votée par les yvelines pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire près de
18 millions d'euros ont été débloqués
pour les commerces du département depuis
juin 2020 normalement nous ne sommes pas
habilités à apporter des aides
économiques directs donc nous le faisons
en passant par les mairies qui elles
peuvent le faire et nous le faisons
parce que nous sommes le département de
la solidarité
enfin le l'institution de la solidarité
solidarité individuelle le département
gère les aides sociales mais solidarité
territoriale aussi c'est à dire le
département essaye d'aider toutes les
communes et à chevreuse onze
établissements bénéficier de ce
dispositif dont des restaurants des
cafés ou encore des métiers liés à
l'événementiel le département rembourse
le loyer avec un certain plafond
rembourse une partie des emprunts
cette boutique ouverte depuis mai 2000
20 aurait pu fermer ses portes sans
cette aide n'a jamais eu l'occasion
d'ouvrir la boutique
donc du coup on n'a jamais eu de
retombées financières et même si à côté
de cette activité on a un atelier
d'ébénisterie et ça permet pas de
couvrir l'intégralité des charges de la
boutique donc sans aide on aurait
probablement déjà fermée au total 48
1500 euros ont été refinancés par le
département à la commune de chevreuse
les commerçants chevreuse en ont besoin
je pense que leur malheureusement vous
voyez surtout le dispositif un
commerçant n'a pas pu n'a pas pu faire
faire face et a dû fermer mais
aujourd'hui on a rencontré une dizaine
de commerçants pour eux je pense qu'ils
l'ont ils l'ont dit ils l'ont rappelé
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui leur a
permis de traverser cette période le
département continuera à aider les
commerces dans les prochains mois
jusqu'à la fin de la crise sanitaire
dans les yvelines plus de 14 mille 600
commerces sont actuellement éligibles à
ce dispositif